[Music]
Instagram how to section Instagram is
one of the fastest growing social media
networks it's appealing format and
functionality have driven people and
businesses away from traditional
networks like Facebook video content is
the most popular content type on
Instagram so it's obvious that we need
to dedicate one lesson to how to create
optimize and promote your video posts on
Instagram we will start this lesson with
showing you how to make great Instagram
videos and talk about different types of
videos for Instagram and we will then
demo you how to use to various video
capturing and editing tools you will
find in the Instagram app we will close
this lesson with how businesses can use
Instagram and how you can make money
with it Instagram has extensive features
to create and promote videos
particularly with the growing appetite
in using Instagram stories video is the
most important content form on Instagram
it is important though to make sure that
before you start creating your video you
have a good idea of what you want to
achieve with it is it to create
awareness to generate leads or are you
answering questions that clients may
have utilize the video editing features
that Instagram has or use some external
apps if you want to go beyond what the
Instagram has to offer there are enough
tools for you to make your Instagram
video a visual feast as you can only
create that on Instagram
shooting and editing a great video
video is now the most shared content
type on Instagram we're in the early
days Instagram video was only 15 seconds
long nowadays you can upload 60-second
videos and turn multiple videos from
your camera roll into one video clip and
today Instagram has lots of different
options within the app to create videos
and optimize them for the newsfeed or
for stories recently Instagram announced
a GTV they're trying to take on YouTube
with a dedicated video sharing app for
vertical and landscape videos with a
maximum length of 60 minutes for
verified accounts or accounts with a
large audience however anyone using the
app will be able to upload up to 10
minutes of content to the platform all
in all Instagram today is a fantastic
network for brands to build brand
awareness and to showcase their products
or services to shoot great videos for
Instagram you need to be aware of a few
things
first of all you need to shoot the video
for Instagram and Instagram has its own
video formats video for a news feed tend
to be square whereas video for the
stories must be vertical the aspect
ratio for vertical videos is 9 by 16
which gives you a perfect 90 degrees
flip for normal widescreen video it's
also better to use your phone's native
camera this will give you better control
over exposure and focus Instagram will
allow you to upload multiple clips and
then edit them within the Instagram app
also think about short form versus
long-form videos stories are good for
short clips where as IG TV lends itself
for longer videos short videos are great
for explaining things that can be
chopped up in steps like recipes or
how-to videos long videos are good for
brand experiences and interviews
additionally it goes without saying you
always need to think about what you want
to achieve with your video
what's your end goal do you want new
followers do you want to
into engagement with your followers or
do you want to drive traffic to your
website all questions you need to think
about before you start shooting your
video video editing in external apps
once you have shot your video you can do
some basic editing within the Instagram
app you can also edit your video outside
Instagram the best environment for
editing your video is on your desktop
computer apps like Adobe Premiere from
Microsoft or iMovie from Apple will give
you an extensive range of video and
audio editing options you can then save
the edited file and move it to your
phone via Google Drive for instance
after which you can import the video
file into Instagram there are also many
video editing apps for your mobile they
won't give you as many features as to
desktop video editing but they come a
long way one of my favorite apps is
video show what a like about video show
is that it has a wide range of templates
you can use as a format for your edited
video it also comes with an extensive
song and music library video categories
so what type of video would work best on
Instagram Instagram lends itself for
what we call snackable videos a
snackable video is short compelling and
entertaining and they are designed to
drive the viewer to some sort of action
like driving them to a landing page or
to a filling forum here are some
examples of topics for your next
Instagram video it can feature your
product features to show your followers
what products you carry and why those
products are unique you can show your
property in action this is great for
breaking up the monotony of stage
product features you can also give a
sneak preview in these type of videos
you announce news with a teaser which
gives your followers a sneak peak of
what is to come behind the scene videos
work very
well on Instagram they are great for
building a more personal relationship
with your audience think of office tours
staff introductions a day in the life of
tutorials will show your fans how to use
your product
and finally video series they are great
for building a community and for
engaging with them once your community
has seen an episode and they like it
they may want to come back for more
video types
besides different topics for your videos
you can also think about different
formats for your videos looping videos
can be created within the Instagram app
looping video start automatically from
the beginning after the clip finishes
they can be very creative and work well
to showcase moveable product features
stop-motion video is an animation that
is captured one frame at a time with
physical objects that are moved between
frames when you play back the sequence
of images rapidly it creates the
illusion of movement both iOS and
Android have lots of apps to create
stop-motion video in a time-lapse video
you capture lots of photos of a scene
over a period of time these images are
then put together to create a seamless
sped up video time-lapse videos work
very well to show how something is built
or made and finally hyperlapse videos
these are videos that allow you to
squeeze several minutes of film into the
one-minute maximum set by Instagram they
are a bit like time-lapse videos but the
camera is moving these videos are great
to show behind the scene footage how to
use Instagram video options
there are various ways that you can make
a video on Instagram so let me show you
how to do that if you go to the
Instagram app it takes you to the
newsfeed where you can browse to make a
quick video you just click on the plus
button and that takes you to this shot
of my phone for instance you need to
make sure you activate video if you
click on the button you can then make
your video you click again to stop
recording and your video is ready you
can now play the video and if you are
happy with it you click Next and then
you can add a filter if you want to I
will come back to filters and editing
later then you just click Next write a
caption tag people add a location and
share it your video is now posted on
Instagram this is the simple way there's
also a more advanced way of making your
video so let me discard this video go
back to the newsfeed we're now in the
newsfeed the creative way to create
video is go to your Instagram stories to
access your Instagram stories you can
swipe to the right or you can also click
on the little camera on the top left of
your screen that takes you to the same
video screen and now you see that you
have more options you can see that here
at the bottom you can do live video you
can do normal video you can select
boomerang video you can do super zoom
you can focus on your video rewind your
video and record hands-free so let me
explain these in a bit more detail for
normal video you just click on the video
button and then you can see that it's
recording and when you're ready with the
recording then you let go of the button
and what you see now is that you have
some extra options at the top where you
can add effects stickers drawings or
text so this is the simple way of making
a video with added effects you can also
go for live video and this is just like
Facebook life when you click on go life
then
Instagram will announce it to your
followers and then you can start your
life broadcast when you're ready with
your life broadcast Instagram will ask
you if you want to post it on your
stories or in your news feed and then
you're done with your broadcasts a very
creative way of making videos is using
boomerang boomerang was a separate app
which became very popular
it was then acquired by Instagram a
boomerang video is a video that repeats
itself if I click on boomerang I'm going
to get the phone and I will turn it then
when you look at the video I created you
see how the video repeats itself all the
time you can do a lot of creative things
with the boomerang effects you can make
people move back and forwards you can
make objects move up and down and then
post them as short repeating videos you
also see that you can change the camera
into selfie mode and you can add some
special overlay effects as well so
there's different filters I quickly scan
through those when you're in selfie mode
you can have funny face alterations as
well so lots of different effects that
you can create here so now let's look at
the super zoom video the super zoom is a
bit like paparazzi video also with
different effects that you can add to it
so for instance I want hearts on this
video click on it and then it will zoom
in and you will see hearts popping down
and here is the stamp effect click on it
and there you go when I do a focus video
it makes the background blurred with
rewind video you can make the video
playback by itself and then finally
there's the hands-free video if you
click on hands-free you don't have to
keep on pressing the record button so
you have more freedom in camera movement
when you choose this option so these are
the different types of video that you
can make on Instagram
how to use Instagram video options and
filters to show you how the effects work
on Instagram I can go to Instagram and
then into the story creation mode and
here I can just make a normal video I
can pan and move the video around a bit
so the video is ready now and Here I am
in the screen where I have the different
options to add creative effects to my
video so this is what I can do first I
can download a video with my phone by
clicking the downward arrow I can then
get different effects I can add stickers
I can play without sounds I can draw on
the screen and I can add text there are
many different options and when you
click on the effect button at the bottom
you see the effects that you can add to
your video there are effects that can be
added when there is a face on the screen
but there are also effects that can be
added as an overlay over the video
we can also add stickers like a location
sticker an invention or a hashtag
sticker interesting thing about these
text type stickers is that when you add
these Instagram will actually understand
the text and will add them to the index
for search you can easily move the
stickers over the screen you can add a
time or a date and you can also add
quizzes so you can ask a question for
instance do you like this and then
people can actually answer by dragging
the slider you can do a poll and there's
a whole range of other stickers that you
can add to your video
you can draw as well you can have a thin
line or a thick line you can change the
color you can do special effects and you
can erase as well so you can do many
differents effects with this you could
create an effect where you wipe out the
whole screen and then with the eraser
you can refill sections of the video you
can get text and then when you're done
with it you can add a video to your
stories or save them as highlights on
your profile page or you can share it on
your newsfeed monetizing your Instagram
videos
there are many different ways to make
money with Instagram you can make money
as an influencer by creating sponsored
video posts these are videos where you
promote a product from a brand and the
brand will reward you for giving them
access to your followers tap influencer
is an excellent app to connect brands
with influences you can also sell your
videos Instagram is a great place to
showcase your content
20:20 is an excellent website where you
can promote and sell your video content
and of course there is affiliate
marketing where you can promote your
products from your affiliate partners
and get a commission on each sale share
sale is a website where you can search
for potential affiliate partners or why
not sell your Instagram account if you
no longer want to manage it
famous web is the place where you can do
this finally Instagram can also help you
indirectly to make money you could use
it to promote your YouTube channel and
as we have learned in this course there
are many ways of making money through
YouTube takumi is one of the leading
online platforms where small influencers
can get connected with big global brands
when you have more than 1,000 followers
and you have good content you will be
able to use this network to identify
brands to work with here are two
takeaways of this lesson video has
become the top content type share it on
Instagram and today Instagram is a whole
range of options to create and optimize
your videos for the newsfeed and for the
stories short videos of maximum 60
seconds are best for Instagram Instagram
uses looping videos they start
automatically from the beginning after
the clip finishes use looping videos to
showcase a fun or versatile profit
feature instagram has many different
video styles in the stories camera and
once you've shot your story video you
have plenty of options to customize them
takumi is an online play
form where micro influences can connect
with big global brands to sell their
original content hi there if you like
this video subscribe to the simple learn
YouTube channel and click here to watch
similar videos to nerd up and get
certified click here